one of my favorite statements in all of
business is if it's worth doing it's
worth doing well most people take that
as oh I should do a really good job at
everything and that's not the right way
to think about it it's actually that
most things aren't worth doing if you
look at someone who's more successful
than you and you look at their schedule
it's not that they have more hours in
the day than you and it's not that
they're doing more things than you it's
that they're doing different things than
you it's not about what they're doing
that you aren't but about what they
aren't doing that you are the leverage
they get on the few activities they do
are getting outsized Returns versus all
the activity you're doing